[Music]
good morning I'm max tegmark and it's a
great pleasure to welcome you all to
Asilomar first of all I would like
everybody who's wearing an organiser
nametag to stand up any questions you
have these are all the friendly faces
you should remember these are the people
you should all go ask I think we might
all right see it works so I would like
to thank all the organizers first of all
who've worked so hard to make this
happen thank you so much folks it's been
really wonderful to work with you I
would like secondly thank yon tahleen
Elon Musk
Alexander tomash the open philanthropy
project and the Center for brains minds
and machines whose generosity has made
this whole conference possible so thank
you so much now please raise your hand
if this is the first time that you're
organizing a conference organized by the
attending a conference organized by the
future of life Institute so for those of
you just raise your hand let me tell you
what we are all about our goal is simply
to make the future of life to help make
the future life as awesome as possible
by making sure that the growing power of
our technology is matched by the growing
wisdom with which we managed it and who
attended the Puerto Rico conference we
did two years ago so your hands all
right let's have a round of applause for
the old timers here yeah it's great
and the reason we should thank I want to
thank all of you in particular is
because the process that you guys all
started in Puerto Rico has had a huge
positive impact in the two years hence
and the goal of this morning's session
is to really highlight what's happened
since Puerto Rico in all these different
areas in economics in AI itself and AI
safety
in law ethics and governance one amazing
impact that happened thanks to Puerto
Rico was thanks to the generosity of
Elon Musk in the open flattery project
we've been able to fund 37 research
teams around the world who have been
hard at work and have already published
a dizzying list of fascinating papers
here in a font way small to read another
amazing thing that's happened is since
then there's been a real surge of
conferences about making AI beneficial
around the world typically at the
mainstream AI conferences this is what
happened just in 2015 alone and in 2016
things totally exploded with dozens of
conferences on keep making AI beneficial
so it's really exciting
another amazing impact of Puerto Rico
and this process has been that the not
that small nonprofit organizations
working towards this goal have grown a
lot and been joined by a whole bunch of
exciting new ones didn't exist before
so more funding a lot of more talented
people getting into this and it's not
just happening in nonprofits and in
academia
also in industry we've seen the birth of
this amazing industry partnership on AI
safety which is well represented here
and there's also been as you're all
aware a gazillion different reports
published now by the US government by
Stanford 100 and so on and hit I Triple
E and so far dozens and dozens and
what's so nice is that the AI community
now is being heard and really excited
that the AI community has engaged in
this conversation and started deleted
because if you go read these reports
they all have AI researchers involved in
them and I think this is a very exciting
development and not just AI researchers
either but economists legal scholars F
assists the same wonderful
interdisciplinary mix of people that I
have the pleasure of looking at right
now in this room so thank you all who
came to Puerto Rico and helped start
this wonderful process which were
contained
here in a Silla Mar thank you again
[Applause]
[Music]